are we talking about julia fox and her
sexual proclivities
yeah please inform me no you have to
inform me you're the one that's been
jerking off to it all night
you like that yeah julia fox that's me
dude that's what you're jerking off too
why do you like that i just love i'm
right-wing sing i love i love yo right
wing sing i love the color it's the
first one
now can you can you run it back to the
beginning mark and can we hear what
she's saying she's on the call her daddy
podcast
perfect her muted that's
this is just the trailer this is just
the trailer for her on the caller daddy
podcast shouts to uh alexandra cooper
you're welcome for helping you secure an
extra 30 million [ __ ] dollars so you
can answer a dm and come on a goddamn
podcast yeah she ain't done nothing over
here lowkey dove knows her boyfriend and
still can't get her on the [ __ ]
podcast
she is protecting her brand from what
i think she's had a couple issues from
your third episode drinking fits no i'm
not having a drinking food how can she
protect her family you're drinking you
scared me how am i scaring you wait what
is her sorry what is her name what is
her brand i don't know but looking at
mark is pissing me off
okay
what do you want me for my hair
sunglasses dude i hate you so much this
is the sunglasses is it the sunglasses
definitely contributing take them off
take them off your head yeah you've got
to switch it up dude
let me see
oh so much well now you look like you
look like [ __ ] but al actually can pull
off those [ __ ] glasses you look like
morpheus no he does he looks like the
key maker
it's a matrix reference as well thank
you alex
thank you al
matrix
it's the new matrix
oh my god
i'm sorry i'm trying to steer the
country in the right direction right now
i don't have time for your [ __ ]
movies about woke red pills you know
what i mean dude that movie was the
first [ __ ] red pill dude yeah you
wouldn't be here without that movie made
by two trans women respect
what's redder than that
they're trying to get
periods i don't know guys i don't know
guys i don't know
i don't know
that would have been good if you it's
kind of fun all right this is what julie
fox had to say all right this is just a
little little piece let me see know that
they will never be worthy to have that
like the the [ __ ] they'll never be good
enough for the [ __ ]
good use of music
torture room kiss my feet
i could smother them maybe sit on their
face or dominatrix but they'll never
ever be good enough for my vagina i'm
into like weirdly like like partner like
swapping and then like watching or
something so like foursomes
yeah
rumor has it you're dating someone new
have you guys put a label on what was
your first impression do you think
kanye's boots are sexy how did you guys
leave it before you went to new york why
do you not consider it what do you say
to people who claim this is not a real
relationship have you ever felt in these
moments like a little overwhelmed no
no oh good answer
actually i thought that was a good
answer
no
like
i sh
i don't know if you guys get the sense
but like i i watch her and i'm like oh
yeah she's been waiting for this her
whole life yeah yeah and she's like i
finally you guys realize that i deserve
all of this attention yes
right does that absolutely basically why
do you feel that i get that feeling why
do you feel that because all the girls
that want to be chosen that's being
chosen
that's a pinnacle that's drafted number
one overall that's what they want to be
drafted yeah and now she's like oh i got
this limelight i'm off but i'll play it
the right way
this is for round two for her so good
it's so good uncut gems she was just
supposed to be like an advisor
and she was in the part and she was so
authentic she was teaching them what the
real situation was in that film yeah so
she already is shown like no no me being
me
works so yeah but that was fifth overall
traffic now she's going first first in
the league
best pretty fire
going brazy i need you both to take off
those sunglasses i'm seeing the world 5d
now for the first time okay why i don't
know i see amazing i can't believe is
how he sees all the time
whoa dude yeah everyone's black it's
awesome let's go black history glasses
that's the best world that's what i'm
saying bro i'm in wakanda let's go
except biggie he's white now
it has reversed the face
[Laughter]
al can you please take the glasses off
yeah it's absolutely infuriating why
don't you try i think that i think
that's what you're making i'm not gonna
watch i'm not gonna wear them
that's what happened when i threw the
lip gloves i just didn't catch it bro
just catch it who'd you throw the lip
gloss he tried to kill you remember
you're trying to take your life oh my
god dude i hate you so much why you look
awful can you try these on all right
guys we'll take a break for a second
because i got to make sure them dicks
are hard you know what i'm saying that's
what i do i keep dicks hard
with the help of blue chew with mostly
blue chew matter of fact 100 of it is
blue chew same active ingredients is
inside viagra cialis but this is the
true this is the one that we rock with
and we're happily married over here
thank you thank you blueis you know what
i'm saying keeping them unions together
forever how can you get it for free i'll
tell you all you gotta go all you gotta
do is go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code flagrant okay and then you
get it for free just pay five dollars
shipping just pay final shipping to keep
your marriage to start a merits to keep
your side chick happy she's not yapping
at all because you're delivering the
pipe okay bluechew.com make sure you use
the promo code flagrant you got it okay
now let's get back to this exclusive
patreon clip you can listen to the whole
episode at patreon.com flagrant2 indulge
join the [ __ ]
yeah sure yeah these that they don't
work
they don't work they don't
work they don't care about sunglasses
all right let's zoom right on hold on
actually low key dude
you don't look horrible
no
no you don't look horrible dude i'm
leaving him on i'm not gonna lie
honestly
yeah
you killed it i mean you look really
cool hey hold on you look [ __ ] cool
dude
[Laughter]
i don't know why it's so funny but it is
your turn one
to take them a little bit down this one
centimeter bang i mean
half the distance back okay split the
difference that's i mean right there you
literally look [ __ ] cool dude yeah
hey i feel it i feel cool what's up
america
no you cannot allow a white woman to
disrespect herself like that no this is
american bro that's for the minorities
she's winning olympic gold medals for uh
climbing for social climate what is oh
social climbing yeah that is okay let's
talk about that that's an olympic gold
right there that is true so she social
climbed herself
up to
the pinnacle as kanye the pinnacle is
that number one i mean if i mean
nancy reagan throated herself to the
first lady that's true that's a good
point i don't know if she's top third
first lady but kim's a first lady both
of them are lames because asap got the
crown bro
rihanna's not american
funny olympics
in america not american doesn't count
i thought you'd have my back on this
i'm with you yeah obviously you're going
to claim you are you guys are american
heard you speak about rihanna in the
history of our friendship performative
performative what
[Laughter]
faking it your performance tim's on you
got them three sizes too big i saw that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you got two big
tims on dude you want everybody to think
you got big old [ __ ] feet you hired
when i get the wrong size i see you i
know i can see it i see you walking
around you take them off you got the
wrong size pants you still haven't fixed
it yet
you're right about that
i wear the wrong size pants why i wear
them too small for what reason so the
people can feel comfortable if they have
to wear hand-me-downs so he can
i'm worried about it it'll actually be
hand-me-ups but it is
what you're doing is absolutely
ridiculous
tell them the truth about how you walked
in here
you walked in here with slides here you
were going to a [ __ ] pickup
basketball game and you threw those tims
on just for the podcast
you [ __ ] lie to the people all right
you [ __ ] tell them what you're saying
so far you're saying i walked in here
with swaggy that's what i heard it
wasn't i didn't say what slides you're
wearing did i
i didn't say what slides are we talking
kanye slides no what slides we thought
you were you were just click clocking
with your [ __ ] japanese
geisha slippers dude when you walked in
dude
wooden the wooden jewels the wooden ones
yeah do you not know what those are no i
don't know oh convenient that is pretty
convenient now you just forget that you
[ __ ] click clocked up in here dude we
don't culture really appropriate we
don't do that oh what
a trophy
this [ __ ] been getting
everywhere
okay [ __ ] you and your size 14
timberlands
[Applause]
this guy chirping in
thank you so
did you see shaq's foot huh did you see
shaq's foot what size you're a big foot
guy yeah yeah yeah no no i didn't want
to hit you i want to throw it back
barefoot oh yeah nails what about it
jack's got the most insane feat maybe of
all time gnarly
dude
they all have bad feet yeah athlete's
got bad feet right that's why [ __ ]
athlete's foot oh that's a good point
it's not a compliment this is brutal
right here
[Music]
the ashes in the shape of the lopes
i mean he's a legend dude absolute
legends jack's a legend yeah you're
worth half a billy i think you could
have your feet whatever you want that's
confidence though you go yo my feet look
crazy look at him look at him dude i'm
worth having billy bro i'm not even
wearing shoes no more sound that's shack
dawg that's an athlete bro
we can't have feet like that
al you might not yet not yet everybody
my feet are beautiful [ __ ] out of here
bro i think that's even i think they're
ugly now so even wearing them [ __ ]
shoes all the time you know you stop
wearing stuff and disrespect remember
always have his toes out all the time
his feet have gotten objectively uglier
they have how do you guys yeah
left to left
you might got me if i put my right foot
out you'll cut your leg off at the
[ __ ] side
that's how embarrassed you'll be you'd
rather be oscar pistorius than go right
foot to right foot with me
so let's do it right now you're not
ready take it off i'm not going to take
my take out the clothing off dude
look at that oh you'll jump 360 but you
won't take your shoe off
that's it two days ago you sore still
you've been walking outside
have we tricked the people into thinking
it's two days rather convinced
dude you look so goddamn cool at some
point i'm gonna [ __ ] everybody dude
everybody can you literally are tom
cruise right now stop gun
but he hides one of his best qualities
yes dude no no but then you get the top
gun like that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
let me suck his dick right there
having nice eyes is cool with glasses
because you peek over them
you're being humble
my pants just split them so i got the
fat lips
so i got the fat [ __ ] lips because my
pants just hit it with the skin it's
always impromptu and so vivid that's
what it is
the details
spit on my own [ __ ]
we never told people how you clogged up
all of tsa it almost had a national
security risk why did i do that you
don't remember this not what happened
this is what we're doing tsa tsa
pre-check no one's in the airport
there's mad room like we're going
through the line and i go through dove
goes through vala goes through and we're
standing there and shows like
where's my [ __ ] like my backpack and my
jacket are not coming through and he's
like walking around looking at the
people asking ts hey they're kind of
looking around like looking at him kind
of annoyed there's a line of probably 40
people lined up in tsa behind us now and
they're all pre-check mind you so
they're all pissed off like yo can we go
yeah and
they pull them aside they go yeah it
seems like a jacket is stuck in the
x-ray machine
wow can't handle me he looks always goes
yeah
apparently there's a jacket it's like an
x-ray machine i think i know i know who
is
this guy
performance fleece bro
performance fleece are you rocking that
old navy no
and there's nothing wrong with old navy
we should be proud of old navy yeah i
had some [ __ ] cargo shorts as a kid
i had cargo pants too did you have any
you got cargo pants now bro
sit on that out
sit in that there's nothing cargo about
these goddamn pants okay you know what
cargo pants please i got it
i didn't even it was so wrong i didn't
even know where you were going
i'll be honest with you i had no clue
but do you remember cargo pants the
heyday in new york city these were fires
we all had them you know
tan
sometimes if you black you had the camos
[Music]
like his hat extends forward
yeah your eyes are pushed in yes sunk it
but it only feels like it's my forehead
protruding no yeah it's not your
forehead that's sticking out what is it
it's a little combination of both i'm
trying to help him out oh yeah i'm
trying to help him out normal yeah
you're not built like peter dinklage at
all dude
it's not at all dude it's not a [ __ ] at
all what up people you just watch a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace